tonight on Brian Ross investigates
Judgment Day for El Chapo will the
billionaire Mexican druglord
famous for his tunnels and daring
escapes finally be brought to justice
his own words from his interview with
Sean Penn used against him a novel my
upended in a persona seen today among
the 56 witnesses against him even his IT
guy who bugged El Chapo's phones for the
DEA which is a good lesson for everyone
be nice to your IT guy and El Chapo's
wife Emma in the courtroom as her
husband's mistress took the stand oh my
goodness what an iphone you can't help a
double-take on this woman plus are
shouta the reporters who pushed to get
this video revealing what really
happened in the back room of an Indiana
police department from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City this is
Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome after ten weeks
of dramatic testimony a federal jury in
New York will begin deliberations next
week in the case of the billionaire
Mexican drug lord known as el chapo
Spanish for the shorty his name is
Joaquin Guzman once one of the richest
men in the world
accused of importing tens of billion
dollars worth of marijuana cocaine
heroin and methamphetamine into the
United States
chapels own words from an interview done
with Sean Penn for Rolling Stone had
been some of the most compelling
evidence against him
prosecutors have played portions of the
tape for the jury several times actually
recorded while el chapo was on the run
as a fugitive he made no excuses for his
life running the powerful and brutal
Sinaloa drug cartel and said his arrest
and prosecution would make no difference
more than 50 witnesses testified against
el chapo his closest deputies his
accountant even his IT guy who helped
the DEA bug the bosses own phones
catching El Chapo negotiating some of
his massive drug deals
so el chapo got his IT guy to spy on the
people who work for him and then the FBI
got the IT guy to spy on el chapo which
is a good lesson for everyone be nice to
your IT guy also among the trove of
evidence presented by federal
prosecutors some of El chapels ingenious
smuggling plans
there was a submarine trucks with hidden
compartments even plastic bananas
stuffed with cocaine but his most
successful smuggling operations seemed
to have involved tunnels that went under
the Mexican border
the jury saw this video of a u.s.
customs agent giving a tour of one of
the tunnels it came out on the US side
less than a thousand yards from the u.s.
customs office join
now is New York Times reporter Alan
foyer who has covered this trial from
day one Ellen I recall on the first day
of the trial on a rainy November morning
how you got in line in the middle of the
night to make sure you had one of those
limited seats in the courtroom thanks
very much
there's a lot for the jury to absorb
here but it seems to be an overwhelming
case it's an astonishing amount of
evidence that the government is
introduced in this case as you mentioned
it's been not only 56 witnesses it's
been handwritten letters that chapo
wrote to his criminal associates it's
been hundreds of phone calls that were
intercepted with the help of the IT guy
text messages of the most intimate sort
that he wrote to his wife and his
various mistresses even the cartels
sophisticated blackberry Network was
tracked by a wiretap by Homeland
Security Investigations it's just I've
never seen so much evidence the case so
can the jury absorb all that you think
well what's remarkable is that the
witnesses who have been called to
testify 14 of them either worked with or
for chapo and what they've done is it
created a narrative they get up there
and they tell a story and in the most
basic way that story is chapo is a you
know a kind of a young upstart
narco-trafficker in the late 1980s and
he cracks into this business by being
faster than any one of his competitors
in fact before he was known as el chapo
he was called el rapido and from there
we begin to see his ascent in an
incredible way to the point where he's
amassing so much money he's got a ten
million dollar beach house in Acapulco
he's got a ranch with a personnal zoo
he's got you know four private jets and
so you know from there the witnesses
have been able really to kind of give us
a picture of chocos life story so all
the rest of the evidence is just
sort of filling in that that that basic
narrative Ellen well the talk about the
need for a wall to stop drugs from
coming into the country does the
testimony in the El Chapo case seem to
undercut that listen they're the
prosecutors have introduced evidence not
only through the witnesses but law
enforcement agents who made seizures of
various drug loads that chapo plan and I
cannot recall one single seizure of the
I even imagine how many have been
discussed dozens discussed so far that
that a wall would have stopped and
that's for a very simple reason almost
all of the drugs that chapo was
trafficking into the United States came
illegally through legal border
checkpoints you know some were smuggled
across the border in secret compartments
of passenger cars some were hidden in
cans of jalapeno chilies in the back of
tractor-trailer truck some across the
border in secret compartments inside
cargo trains that were carrying legal
loads of cooking oil some went
underneath the border in tunnels and so
the idea that a wall stretching across
remote areas of the border would have
stopped any of this stuff just doesn't
square with the evidence that we heard
and there's also been testimony about
bribes being paid to Mexican officials
including one witness who alleged the
former Mexican president Enrique Pena
Nieto took a bribe of 100 million
dollars in allegation he has strongly
denied strong evidence listen I mean
indeed the the testimony is about the
the alleged bribe to Pena Nieto's was
the culmination of a drumbeat
of testimony that chapo and his cartel
partners bribed virtually every level of
the Mexican police military and
political establishment there was
testimony that that one of the
architects of the drug war in Mexico a
guy who held
and in position roughly equivalent to
our Attorney General and had previously
held a position roughly equivalent to
our director of the FBI twice received
suitcases full of three million dollars
in cash in a restaurant the there was
testimony that the Mexican military was
paid between ten and fifteen million
dollars to at one point fight Chapo's
bloody drug wars on his behalf
so yeah the alleged by the pena nieto
was very very serious but it was just
part of this you know onslaught of
evidence that almost anyone with
authority in mexico could ultimately be
corrupted and as you know Alan drug
dealers have been able to act with
impunity in Mexico for decades because
of corrupt officials sometimes police
are simply asked to choose their metals
a lead bullet or a silver bribe and it
goes back to the birth of the Sinaloa
cartel long before El Chapo took charge
Netflix series narcos focuses on the
Sinaloa cartel's rapid growth fueled by
huge bribes paid to Mexican officials
the storyline involves the true story of
DEA agent Kiki Camarena who was
kidnapped and killed by the cartel in
Guadalajara in 1985 as the narcos series
shows the agent running the guadalajara
office of the DEA was jim jaime
Kuykendall who led the search for his
missing agent and railed against the
corruption of mexican police and
government officials
Kuykendall has since retired from the
DEA and now lives in Loretto texas where
he talked with me by skype about the
message that could be sent by the El
Chapo trial what's the effect of that
sort of corruption when you're trying to
do your job they're going against the
drug traffickers and officials you're
dealing with are corrupt being paid by
them well you can never be certain that
the people you're dealing with or are
being honest with you and of course you
always have to watch your back so what
is the message that's being sent to
Mexico by this trial it's going to take
a Mexico have to decide that they
don't want that kind of violence any
more than Mexicans can stop it when they
want him and so why don't they I guess
it's not financially feasible that would
be one reason it's the money it's the
billions and billions of dollars oh well
yeah the money that the root of all of
it yes of course it it it's the root of
it parents the root of it in the United
States and so for you as you see all
this unfolding it must be somewhat
frustrating you know that there was an
opportunity 30 years ago that really had
wasn't taken that's great Jim cock and
all I want to thank you very much for
joining us today thank you
by the way the actor who plays El Chapo
in the Netflix series Alejandro Etta
showed up in court in New York earlier
this week to see his subject firsthand
having him that close it Shooks me it's
I'm intimidated by you as you have
reported the trial has become a big
tourist attraction people coming from
all over to see El Chapo
it's remarkable people started flying in
from Denver one guy I talked to worked
in a paper mill in Wisconsin and flew in
for one day see this file we had I was
calling him narco tourists
you know people from Lithuania and it
just built and built and built to the
point that you know these people who
just wanted to come see chopper were
showing up at the courthouse it you know
five six in the morning in order to get
a seat amazing one of the most dramatic
moments in the trial is you know Alan
came as prosecutors called
his former mistress to the stand with
his wife Emma looking on his wife Emma
did not want to talk about any aspect of
the trial when we caught up with her as
she left the courtroom this week the
scene when El Chapo's mistress testified
with Emma looking on was captured by
renowned courtroom artist Christine
cordell cordell talked with me outside
the court this week about that moment I
sit next to Emma his wife and she's just
like
oh my goodness what an iPhone you can't
help a double-take on this woman she's
just like tied up like a bow and El
Chapo you know I'm quite sure he's had
something done to his face because you
know how when someone's had a little
face work you don't really see the
expressions register when the man smiles
it's kind of more like a grimace and do
you see emotion from his wife you know
she's a funny one I mean I'm quite sure
that she's listening intently and all
there but she plays with her hair and
looks at her fingernails and sometimes
she smiles a little and I've seen her
look actually very serious and there was
one day when she actually she brought
her children to court and they rolled in
a shopping cart with 4748 que 47s and
she saw that roll into the courtroom she
grabbed her children and ran out the
door
no chapel's wife has been in court
almost every day saying very little to
reporters she is a former beauty queen
born in the United States reporters say
she's put on a brave face knowing her
husband may spend the rest of his life
in prison dealing with the sordid
details of her husband's mistress
relationship of course I was rolling
Emma the really fun day was a day when
they poured the matching velvet lasers I
think that was to show solidarity they
both had the same we're a couple yeah
we're the we're the king and the Queen
and you're just in your prison garb babe
you know and Cornell said el Chapo's
mistress broke down in tears after her
testimony the day that she first took
the stand it was emotional because she
said that this whole thing was confusing
to her that she was testifying against
him
and you could hear her crying in the
back she when she left the room they had
a mic on her and she was sobbing it was
the whole courtroom we were hearing her
sobbing because she had to testify
against the man she loved her once loved
she said she was very confused by it
because she really thought that they
were a team partners Alan for let me ask
you what moment stand out the most to
you after ten weeks of this trial so
many I mean you know to me the the
parade of witnesses who have been in
this trial have just been incredible
we've had everyone from Chapo's chief
Colombian cocaine supplier who utterly
altered his face with plastic surgery so
that his chin his eyes his forehead his
ears his hair every single part of him
had been physically altered you know the
IT guy we had you know the the things
we've learned about the just insanity of
cartel culture there was testimony that
one of chocos allies early in his career
when he was in prison took a contract to
kill another cartel member with a
cyanide laced Arriba
there was testimony that chapo and his
crew used to relax on their days off by
taking target practice with a bazooka we
heard the story of one of chapels
earliest employees who ran afoul of
chapo and was imprisoned and when
Chapo's assassins came to kill him the
night before that happened a mariachi
band played all night outside his cell
one of chocos sort of most beloved and
well recognized songs and it just went
on and on and on in this kind of gothic
onslaught of just insanity some consider
him a folk hero that certainly the
testimony indicates he was brutal and
extremely violent listen one of the the
last cooperating witness that we heard
Hobbs was one of Chapo's
asin's Sicario a trained killer and he
testified that chapo had twice
personally killed people
in one of those instances it was two
members of a rival cartel called Los
Zetas the these members of Los Zetas the
witness said had been brutally beaten
for hours with tree branches and and
rifles to the point where their bodies
were like rag dolls chapo then had them
brought out to a bonfire at one of his
mountaintop hideaways on the backs of
ATVs and he ultimately shot them both at
close range in the head and ordered his
order ordered his team of killers to
throw the bodies onto the bonfire and he
told them I don't want any bones to
remain and so the team of killers spent
all night the testimony went feeding the
bonfire so that these guys were utterly
incinerated and then in the morning to
make sure there were no bones if they
found any shards they personally drowned
those shards into the dust oh my
goodness Alan foyer thank you so much
for being with us today we'll be
following your coverage if the trial
begins to the jury begins it still
relations next week
up next a shout out to the reporters who
pushed hard to turn up a very disturbing
video when we come back
tonight I shut out four reporters who
wouldn't take no for an answer
Christian scheckler of the South Bend
Tribune teaming up with Ken Armstrong of
the nonprofit ProPublica push to get key
documents and a telling video to expose
police brutality that otherwise would
have gone unreported it was only after
this video was finally made public that
it became known what really happened to
the suspect being dragged out of this
police car and police officials and
officers in Elkhart Indiana held to
account the man's name was Mario Guevara
ledesma under arrest for domestic
battery so he was brought into a
detention area at the police department
he was placed on a chair with his uh
hence cuffed behind his back
reporter Christian suckler of the South
Bend Tribune had already been working on
how the Elkhart Indiana Police
Department handled allegations of
misconduct when he came across this case
at one point he turned and began to spit
towards one officer that officer and
another and then jumped on top of them
and punched him in the face repeatedly
but the police at first put out a much
different version Police Chief Ed Wood
Bigler downplayed it to the police
oversight Commission and I think they
just went a little overboard when they
when they took him to the ground without
the video
the Chiefs version a little overboard
became the official version he made no
mention of them throwing any punches and
really he just consistently downplayed
what had really happened in the police
stations detention area Ken Armstrong is
a reporter with a non-profit group
ProPublica which has created a fund to
help support local investigative
journalism getting the video in Indiana
made all the difference
yeah he's left on the ground bleeding
afterwards
for about six minutes then he's taken
out on a stretcher you know so this was
not something where two officers simply
went a little overboard
it went well beyond that when the South
Bend Tribune published a video it also
identified the two other officers in the
room and the two other officers included
the mayor's son I'm sergeant drew nice
he was the only supervisor in the room
and the other officer in the room at the
time the meeting occurred was the head
of the local Fraternal Order of Police
and neither of those two officers
stopped the beating as it occurred but
they walked over as it ends and one of
them says stop and if Christian and with
your help had not pushed for the video
what do you think would have happened I
don't think anything would have happened
you know when the police chief
reprimanded the two officers in June of
2018
he concluded his letter reprimand with
the line I now consider this matter
closed with an exclamation point
but the Tribune reporting made it
impossible to close the case right now
elkhart leaders are dealing with the
department in disarray tonight police
chief edwin Bigler suspended without pay
top police officials blamed the
newspaper for all its problems
how carts assistant police chief todd
Thayer made an impassioned speech about
his anger over the reports in the
tribunal everything is going why are
they coming over here into our backyard
and trying to disrupt everything that we
built since then the chief was forced to
resign the mayor has announced he will
not run for re-election and the two
officers who actually threw the punches
seen in the video they have been charged
with misdemeanor battery and are
awaiting trial
they have pleaded not guilty it's the
kind of local reporting that is so
critical and it's the kind of local
reporting that's suffering given the
landscape and journalism these days you
know so it's one of the things that from
public I was hoping to address with the
local reporting network who in some
small way make up for that and and to
help bolster this
critical reporting in local news rooms
so a shout out to those two reporters
Kristen sheckler and Kent Armstrong and
their organizations the South Den
Tribune and ProPublica for refusing to
accept the official version of events a
reminder for all that journalism is not
meant to be stenography and the good
news is that ProPublica is now funding
some 14 other local investigative
journalists around the country that's
our program for this week thanks for
joining us we'll see you here again next
week